this video is brought to you by Thrive
Market
[Music]
the year 2022 and we're Banning books
yeah books not guns or uh or the spread
of misinformation or carbon emissions or
artificial sweeteners or Kid Rock were
Banning books including ones considered
Classics like Tony Morrison's The Bluest
Eye according to the American Library
Association as of August 2022 there have
been some 681 challenges involving some
1 651 books up from 273 books in 2020
and 566 in 2019. FYI a challenge is when
a person or group requests that a book
be removed from a library last November
the Ala put out a statement on the topic
in it they argued that a few
organizations have decided that the
voices of the marginalized have no place
on Library shelves to this end they have
launched campaigns demanding the
censorship of books and resources that
mirror the lives of those who are gay
queer or transgender or that tell the
stories of persons who are black
indigenous or persons of color under the
guise of call following these books
subversive or immoral the Ala argues
these groups have promoted government
censorship by appealing to elected and
non-elected officials and even resorting
to intimidation tactics targeting
Library workers Educators and school
board members
[Applause]
one of these groups florida-based moms
for Liberty have advocated for the
Banning of any books that exemplify
things like critical race Theory they
even offered a 500 reward on information
about Educators who teach materials
which express views associated with CRT
they were also vehemently anti-masking
during the peak of the covet pandemic so
I guess Liberty a word meaning freedom
from government restrictions has a
pretty fluid definitions for these moms
okay let's dive into the debate in this
wisecrack Edition why do we keep Banning
Books Okay I want to take a second and
tell you all about this video sponsor
Thrive market now they are an online
membership-based grocery store on a
mission to make healthy living easy and
affordable for everyone now I'm sure
like many of you
um I get stressed about the tension
between wanting to eat healthy organic
foods but also stick to a budget and
this is where Thrive Market is great as
they can help you save up to 30 percent
on your grocery bill it's great because
it means I don't have to skip Buy iron
products I'm really excited about
because they're too expensive for
example I love fancy popcorns you know
sue me I love them but they're really
expensive and a lot of stores but with
Thrive I could be snacking on fancy
popcorn every night so I'm happy I know
I'm not the only one who struggles to
even find the time to shop for healthy
groceries and organic products which for
me often involves driving across town in
traffic and then praying to the parking
lot guides that I could get a spot near
the store but with Thrive Market I can
place my order from work or calm and it
arrives right at my doorstep no parking
lot arguments are required and if you're
the type of person excited to save money
on organic groceries you're also likely
someone who cares about the planet and
lucky for you orders of 49 or more are
shipped free and with carbon neutral
shipping from their zero waste
warehouses so you can save time and
money while enjoying high quality
organic products while looking out for
the planet so click on the link in the
description or go to thrivemarket.com
ice crack to place your first order with
Thrive today and when you do you'll
receive a free sixty dollar gift options
this month include cooking staple sets
that come with ingredients and cookbooks
a supplement bundle and a deluxe travel
kit so head to thrivemarket.com
wisecrack to save money and eat better
today now back to the show for our
purposes a Banned Book is a book that
has been removed from a public library
or a school a challenged book is one
that someone has requested be removed so
this conversation does not include
Amazon Banning say a book that denies
the Holocaust book Banning isn't a new
Phenomenon with recent decades seeing
bands on children's novels like Bridge
to Terabithia and Harry Potter as well
as Classics like John steinbecks Of Mice
and Men and Maya Angelou's I Know Why
the Caged Bird Sings recently the rise
of book bands is targeted works that
address topics like race indigenous
people's experiences and queer
narratives and as we see in groups like
moms for Liberty anything they can
associate with CRT is on the must ban
list if you see this acceptable you
belong on a National Registry and not a
school board oh and by the way if you
were ever wondering what our take on the
critical race Theory debate is uh we
made a video on it at the same time
Librarians are becoming subjects of
attack Kimber Glidden former Idaho
library director resigned after months
of harassment because she feared for her
safety she said we were being accused of
being pedophiles and grooming children
people were showing up armed at library
board meetings but book Banning has been
contentious since long before Americans
were bringing guns to library board
meetings what a phrase too that I'm just
saying out loud Americans bringing guns
to library board meetings I'm sure for
many of you that just sounds like a
normal thing that I just said what does
that mean you know what is it what does
it mean pause and think about it okay
now we're back according to librarian
and author Richard ovenden the
significance of books and archival
material is recognized not only by those
who wish to protect knowledge but also
by those who wish to destroy it he notes
that libraries and archives have been
targets of attack throughout history and
Librarians and archivists have even lost
their lives attempting to preserve human
knowledge book burning first made it to
America in 1650 when Massachusetts
Puritans seized a pamphlet written by
William pension his crime arguing that
anyone who was obedient to God and
followed his teachings would get into
heaven so I guess the message of this
ban was that we need heaven to remain
exclusive so people actually want to go
there like when there's a concert and
they tell you it's sold out but it's not
because they're going to release tickets
later but they do that to drive up
prices so I guess the Puritans were the
original Ticketmaster Massachusetts
seems to have a particular urge to burn
or ban books flash forward to the 1920s
and you'll find Boston's elite-filled
watch and Ward Society mobilized to
remove a series of books from libraries
and schools petition in libraries suing
booksellers and bringing obscenity
charges against authors was among the
organization's tactics and it worked
between 1927 and 1929 over 60 titles
were banned in Boston the thing most of
the banned titles had in common is
exemplifying the type of Vice that
offended both the OG Puritans and the
recent Catholic arrivals in the city
mentions of sex were almost sure to get
you banned the phrase abandoned Boston
became so ubiquitous that it was even
used as a marketing slogan to entice
vice-hungry readers to buy supposedly
immoral books in other parts of the
country but why were the late 20s such a
Flashpoint in America's book Banning
history as historian Paul Boyer argues
book censorship was a means of reacting
to and feeling in control of the changes
brought by the turbulent 1920s the
inter-war period was a time of Rapid
change in everything from economics to
yes literature including lots of what
Ward members saw as impure literature
and it seems like in trying to control
access to ideas those doing the Banning
we're trying to control where the
culture was going Boston wasn't alone in
its censorship happy Elite societies
during the Jim Crow era the daughters of
the Confederacy successfully pushed for
bands of textbooks that did not paint a
sympathetic Narrative of the South and
the Civil War historian Karen Cox
explains that the importance the
daughters placed on historical work
cannot be overstated because they acted
on the assumption that Duty required
them to defend the honor of Confederate
men and women this meant instilling
young people in the South with respect
for the Confederate past and its
principles for the daughters books
especially historical scholarship and
historical memory were according to Cox
a powerful tool of persuasion Beyond
controlling historical narratives book
Banning and burnings have also
historically functioned to silence and
even erase ideas seen as dangerous by
those in power the most glaring example
occurred in Nazi Germany on May 10 1933
a crowd of almost 40 000 students
gathered around a bonfire outside the
Humboldt University of Berlin they
cheered as someone through a bust of
Jewish intellectual Agnes hirschfeld
Into the Fire hirschfeld founded the
Institute of sexual science which housed
scholarship on the study of sex
sexuality and gender with a focus on
promoting the rights of those who didn't
conform to established Norms the crowd
then threw thousands of volumes from the
institute's library Into the Fire along
with other books by Jewish authors and
anyone they considered to be ungerman
Hitler's top propaganda Minister Joseph
Goebbels praised this destruction of
decadence and moral corruption as a
strong great and symbolic deed it was
none of these things and it was good
when gerbils died this suggests that
book burning has long been as much a
powerful symbol as it has been a
practical way to prevent those seeking
certain types of Knowledge from
acquiring it and while he famously
didn't write books we see this type of
reaction against new ideas all the way
back in Plato's account of the trial of
Socrates where he was sentenced to death
for exposing the young people of Athens
to ideas that challenged dominant modes
of power while book censorship has been
around for a long time the charges
themselves have remained fairly
consistent these books and still young
people with the wrong values and thus
undermine social order ironically though
Banning a book often serves the opposite
purpose historically there's been no
better way to make a book fly off the
shelves than to ban it as my first
editions of O.J Simpson's if I did it
are going for almost a thousand dollars
on eBay that's true if you're talking
about a very dull graph heavy 1857 book
penned by a South Carolinian arguing
against the economics but not the
morality of chattel slavery it's also
true if you're talking about a 1980s
breakthrough graphic novel Mouse
depicting the experiences of the
author's parents in the German
concentration camp Auschwitz after being
banned last year in a small Tennessee
Town Mouse quickly became an Amazon
bestseller these days the justification
that some organizations in library board
enthusiasts use to challenge and or ban
books have retained a similar flavor
specifically they tend to fall into two
camps one books that contain sexual
content or the suggestion of sexual
difference and two books that portray
U.S history particularly its history of
enslavement and occupation in ways that
might undermine patriotism these days
the second Camp is largely using a
fear-mongering interpretation of
critical race Theory to justify their
attempts to ban books and punish
teachers pan-america an organization
that advocates for the freedom of
expression assembled an index of school
book bans to track Trends about which
books have been targeted over a recent
nine-month period the results were
instructive 41 percent had protagonist
or prominent secondary characters of
color and 22 percent directly addressed
race and racism a third of books
explicitly addressed queer themes or had
queer protagonists one quarter contains
sexual content ranging from sexual
encounters to information about puberty
sex or relationships and 25 percent were
history books biographies or featured
themes about rights and activism this
suggests that a lot of book Banning
today is about censoring experiences
that fall outside of white heterosexual
Norms I want all of the Norms that I
follow to be those the Jerry Seinfeld
experiences nowhere is this more true
than in prison where book review
committees decide which books
incarcerated people are allowed access
to Jessica Phoenix Sylvia a formerly
incarcerated trans woman of color and
writer has detailed how the carceral
system has been restricting access to
ideas by Banning certain topics or books
from prison libraries even when
prisoners bought those books themselves
Sylvia argues books can change lives
France fanon's wretched of the earth is
one book that changed my life the non
says we must Elevate the people expand
their minds equip them differentiate
them and humanize them to do this we
must access ideas and language through
literature I resist the dehumanization
that prisons create which is further
maintained by unjust censorship here's
an unfun fact for you the Michigan state
prison system has banned fanon's work
from their libraries but this recent
wave of censorship has not gone
unnoticed and Librarians have been
mounting their counter-offensive which
while forceful is also very quiet and
respectful when their workers aren't
busy Penning screeds against censorship
some libraries have been lending out
books to non-residents as a way of
broadening access the Brooklyn public
library has an unbanned books program
which provides ebook access to people in
places where book Banning is prominent
like Oklahoma by using QR codes other
technology like the internet archive can
counter attempts to make Books banned in
schools and libraries unavailable or as
a Washington Post headline put it you
can ban a book but can you stop teens
from finding it online another
encouraging sign is the attention that
book Banning has been receiving in the
media in recent months but hey at least
we've moved past actually burning books
okay maybe not moving on still the ala
has found that about 82 to 97 percent of
complaints seeking to ban books continue
to go unreported under these conditions
spreading information about those quiet
but effective attempts to remove books
from the shelves can go a long way in
raising awareness but as we survey the
current rise of book Banning in America
it's worth taking a step back and asking
why all the Panic about out books
according to scholar Emily Knox book
censorship highlights an intimate
relationship between power and knowledge
kind of like we mentioned earlier
regarding the Death of Socrates right
because he got killed because the
knowledge he was encouraging threatened
the positions of those in power so he
had to get God she explains when a group
or individual Endeavors to remove
restrict or relocate an item within a
public institution they are both
demonstrating their concern over the
knowledge contained within the book and
also exercising their symbolic power
over the institution in building her
argument Knox draws on Pierre Bordeaux
to assert that Challengers use symbolic
power as Citizens parents or taxpayers
to shape public institutions in their
Community she states that symbolic power
is important because it is often
misrecognized as something else such as
common sense or Justified actions I.E if
the library or School Board banned a
book by Tony Morrison then well she must
be dangerous bordu defines symbolic
power as those symbolic instruments
including discourse that are used by one
social group that dominate another
social group and according to Knox
censorship also highlights a struggle
for Domination over who has the
authority to determine the boundaries of
legitimate and illegitimate knowledge in
the public sphere that is to say when
the lived experiences of an indigenous
American child growing up on a
reservation aren't considered legitimate
knowledge the age-old domination of
white Americans over indigenous people
only becomes more deeply entrenched and
their exclusion for many facets of
American society are only reinforced
that's because books like all cultural
artifacts play a vital role in helping
us construct a sense of who we are now
at least of which when the ideas they
contain are reinforced by authority
figures I.E teachers French philosopher
Louis altaze explains this via his
theory of interpolation which argues
that our ideas about a given topic are
not something we arrive at on our own
but rather are internalized and accepted
on the basis of what's been presented to
us by our culture and in turn these
ideas shape our subjectivity this is all
encouraged by what altaze called
ideological state apparatuses or isas
which are things like churches families
and schools that reinforce these modes
of subjectivity an example of
interpolation is our association of pink
with young girls and blue with young
boys now this wasn't always the case
back in 1918 a trade publication
earnshaw's infants Department hopefully
explained that the generally accepted
rule is pink for the boys and blue for
the girls anyway today is Iranian
assumption that the pink blue girl boy
dichotomy is inherent to toddler
supposed natural color preferences
exposes the extent to which we
internalize cultural expectations okay
but back to books the knowledge within
their text are crucial to the process of
interpolation I.E the formation of
subjectivity they are a vital way we
internalize ideas about our culture and
they create subjects who in turn
perpetuate certain ideas and cultural
norms and as Norms surrounding racial
and Indigenous identities sexual and
gender identities and so on continue to
shift they're going to remain
flashpoints for folks who would rather
these new Notions not be internalized by
Future Generations basically groups like
moms for Liberty and people like
Christopher rufo know that controlling
the ideas in places like schools and
libraries allows them to use these
ideological state apparatuses to help
create subjects that serve their
ideological aims it's like a sick
version of my plan to make my future
children listen to music I like from a
young age so when they get older I
always have concert buddies to encourage
my own interest and they'll have a
concert buddy who's old enough to buy
them booze because ultimately the matter
of books doesn't just have to do with
broader institutional power over what
information children can access it has a
lot to do with parents specifically
those who are seeking to limit that
access to their children as Emily Knox
explains people are trying to get books
like Mouse banned because they are
afraid that if their children read them
they will have different values than the
values their parents want them to have
that's really what this is about people
are looking to books as dangerous
knowledge and in a democracy where our
education system is intended to produce
well-informed citizens who could weigh
multiple opposing opinions in order to
determine which one they think is best
and maybe even do a better job at it
than their parents before them this all
seems pretty bleak but hey we'll always
have the internet right that you um you
had you you would you could you do you
win what do you guys think let us know
in the comments and also let us know in
the comments what your favorite band
book is a special thanks to all our
patrons if you haven't checked out our
patreon page in a while please do
because it's the best way for you to
directly support the work that we're
doing here on the channel and you got
some great perks as well like extra
content and early videos thanks again to
thrive market for sponsoring this video
don't forget to go to thrivemarket.com
wisecrack to make your first order and
get your free 60 gift today as always
thank you so much for watching and we'll
catch you later
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]